[Applause]
supreme court ruling
that half of oklahoma yeah is like
considered a native american reservation
so
they can't be charged with crimes and
civil situations
within that area uh so basically native
americans go up shoot you and they can't
do anything
i think there there's something tricky
with that it's like
they can't be charged with like city or
state crimes i think they still are like
under federal that makes sense
designation right yeah but yeah that's
true like speeding tickets all that kind
of [ __ ] because they have their own
police yeah
that's wild and i think that you could
look this up to make sure but there is
something interesting i think that tesla
has a factory there
look this up to make sure and then
someone's like yo elon
how you feel about the fact that your
factory's on native land now
and that might be really interesting
because they could be like yo we gonna
need a little piece of that
i think that'd be great you know there's
no i think they're making a pitch
to tesla they're making a pitch to tesla
to bring it there's a guy that did that
in the dirty money series on netflix
okay it's so good
he's i forget what he was but he
basically like set up a company and hit
up these native american chiefs they
were like yo you want to be a founder
and they're like oh that's brilliant
what do i got to do and he's like oh
nothing
i'm just going to funnel my company
through you give you a hundred thousand
a year for nothing they fell for the
founding trick again and get
yo you would have found america no it's
going to work out no it's more like you
found america appreciate you
your job is done it's safe but
apparently that should work though or
like
yeah they were getting money and they
were getting crazy kickbacks and tack
rates and all that stuff that's why like
you ever see dudes on the street selling
hats or selling like shirts or whatever
like that there's one
old dude that got a necklace with a
badge on it
yeah and it's permission to sell and
i think it's easier to get those if
you're a veteran
right so they're giving certain people
the ability to sell things on the street
obviously there's so much street traffic
in new york city you know those are
very coveted yeah right there's only two
things you could sell that aren't
uh that you don't need a badge for
christmas trees and books
you could just sell christmas trees and
books on the streets of new york but
everything else
our records all these different things
we see growing up watching
so what i think a lot of people do is
they find the veteran and go yo you
wanna just sit here with us
we'll do all the work oh [ __ ] you do or
will partner up on it and
you can make money on the street son if
you're doing the tax thing with native
americans if the idea is i don't have to
pay
federal taxes corporation gets taxed at
30
it makes 10 million dollars that's three
million dollars wanna just pay you a
million
so i profit two you get a million let's
go bro
literally you could say i'll give you
three million
yeah and it's even yeah and you don't
gotta deal with the irs breathing down
your neck every two seconds auditing you
all that [ __ ]
you can give them all the money just for
not having a headache i even think
there's subsidies that go along with it
too
oh that's right because you want to
build up that land yeah if you're like a
native
owned company like you get government
stuff you wanted to do black
black reparations take atlanta
something you'd think they would give us
an atlantis not exactly like come on
i mean you're taking it anyway but if
y'all keep breaking enough [ __ ]
they might be like we're talking about
the 40 acres get [ __ ] the mule
just give us the land what neighborhoods
do black people want
go real talk we could take any land as
long as not like
alaska some [ __ ] like nah cause you know
how picky black people are yeah
he said what if we all took our stimulus
checks as black people and just bought
montana
oh and then we just that's ours and
montana's that's black land now what do
you do
see you pick a place that most of us
don't even know where it is on a map
i don't know where mike well it can't be
a place white people want man you gotta
they're good people love monsters that's
white people's [ __ ]
it's like 12 white people jackson this
is what white people do though they
front cause i went to montana what
montana does is it doesn't do any pr for
montana
they specifically iceland greenland that
[ __ ] yup what about the dakotas dakotas
are trash
yo you could get it you can get a south
south you can go to the south
and you all love south sides yeah yo
that could be kind of lit black people
go just give us one place
we're gonna build that [ __ ] up ourselves
and then you have crazy tax subsidies
you have all this other [ __ ] wouldn't it
be nice to have a friendly south for
once too [ __ ]
south where you're accepted bro black
people got to talk
again think about it all the cuisine the
food you could do grills
there could be such nah for real you
guys girls
both girls yeah traeger
yo come on i know about grills dog girls
are popping you should wear yours you
got a set right i do you got to say
this yeah i'm nice i got two
i got one on wilding out and then i got
one from paul with with them come on
these girls it is what it is look but i
think that is an interesting idea take
the land and then
give the whatever rules you will are
allowed to have on your land
dictate the success of that land sound
will there be a louder state
than south dakota so imagine being north
dakota like yo can you turn it down like
that
no you put a knockout on the [ __ ]
border wall can we build a dome
they start calling all north dakota
karen
oh dakotas matter guys yo
this is fire bro i think that's the move
so forget defund the police y'all can
have your own police
oh there you go
i'm with it i'm winning if we have a win
a good amount too so the whole state
it's a dakota
now you're getting we don't know how big
that [ __ ] is where are you going
from a position of leverage yeah yeah
you are leverages guilt and guilt alone
yeah
so we're 13 of the population give us
a state that's 13 percent of the
landmarks
all right fine but then all you all got
to move there not all of us
that's well then no you can't give me 30
not all y'all are moving there
all right 10.
i like how we're american
you see how we already bullied you out
of [ __ ] three percent you know yeah
but no don't take no for an answer yeah
you know but yeah
but we get to stay everywhere
you need russell to negotiate for real
now we taking it
nah that's i think this is interesting
you got to get land you got to get
specific
rights because the interesting thing
about this is once you get your land and
you could do whatever you want on it
if it fails white people get to go
ah you should hey you tried you could
yep
now white people got to be willing to do
to say okay you got it that's it you
[ __ ] you fail that is what it is
and they got to be willing to accept it
when it thrives yes
that's the big part and then they gotta
be like all right we [ __ ] up we
shouldn't have been
we're the best at doing a lot with a
little mmm
so so you don't need a 13. let's give it
down like six percent
not ten two ten and we get to stay okay
real question on behalf of black people
in like three states real question
on behalf of black people what if we
just gave you all the native american
land
and we're like yo if we tried with the
natives
they're getting real ornery about the
football teams it's starting to bother
us
les you you could already be the
blackhawks that's close
you know what i mean you get to keep the
casinos too you get you get to keep
everything
that's there what happens to the natives
though some people numbers alone like
the
amount of money they make off lotto what
happens to the nato you get to have the
natives
you get to have them you get to have
slaves whatever you want to do
you just restart america we're going to
restart america and we'll be like well
what would you do then
let's see what you would have done in
our situation it really looked like
hamilton
i think we would all come together black
we would be like yeah we get it
yeah we get like you know they just
gotta rap politics they just rap
politics we would
all we would have learned it all by now
you